this is what it looks like inside one of
these containers mentioned in de
children's commissioners report this
container this family they've been
living here for the last nine months
we're gonna have a word with them in the
next few moments or so but we just want
to show you around and give you a feel
of what it's like living in an
environment like this this is the
kitchen area before the microwave a sink
if I just take you around here they've
got that fridge not enough space in the
kitchen for the fridge this is where
they store their clothes unable to get a
wardrobe in and inside the container
like this so now to say their clothes
they're just going to take you into a
bedroom this is again their belongings
they have no space to bring chest of
drawers in or or wardrobes so they have
to just get their stuff you know in
corners the children's bedroom is just
on the Left right here and this is where
all the children all between the ages of
to 10 again know where to put their
school uniform so they all have to
remain in bags so let's get a an
understanding that's what it's like but
it's families who live in these
conditions at new-new abu baker and
immortality fair you've been here as
i've said for that nine months or so you
live with your young son here special
needs yes and just still it's just a
complexities and and how difficult it is
for you okay it's very very difficult
for any type of family especially me
having a special a child was my older
side he is almost 18
you know he is more severe is there any
difficulty has no danger awareness and
it has no spoken yet for the council to
choose this kind of property to both
family with a special need child knowing
that my son is a very active child he
needs to run around
he needs to you know like a little out
of steam this place is too too small for
him to let it out steam and we get a
sense of just how small it is but I just
wanted if you could give our viewers you
know perhaps the scope of just how
difficult it is because as you can see
there's no place even we can call a
sitting room the place is the shipping
container this is a cargo container this
is know for human being this is a mental
torture more likely cause more living
here is no family's for nobody maybe for
normal bachelor they can cook off up
temporary accommodation like food they
told us it was a recommendation from the
temporary it became a long thing we
didn't counsel have said that this is
one of the ways in which they're trying
to tackle a coolness crisis on their
hands you know perhaps a lot of people
say to expect her than being on the
streets oh you have just one step across
to be in the stream people on the street
are being a wearing a box we're in a
container containers for an awful human
being is for you to storage things you
get a sense just there how difficult it
is for looting the teeth you're worried
about your safety because you said that
you've entered your self bathroom inside
discontinued yes on the hub I've burned
my arm and it's the stairs are extremely
unsafe because when it rains it gets wet
I knew it
trip over and hurt your knee you were
telling me earlier just how embarrassing
you find it when you have to tell your
friends where you live yeah cuz it's not
like a normal home it feels nothing like
hope it's it's just a seal it's homeless
people but with four walls and a door
and that's those points is that exactly
what the Children's Commissioner has
flagged in her report she says that
these conditions are cramped and they're
not fit Ealing Council meanwhile has
said this is a
this is the most cost-effective way when
it comes to tackling homelessness